I think it's safe to say that all humans
will be intimate with death at least
once in their lives but what if that
intimacy began long before you faced
your own transition from life into death
what would life be like if the dead
literally lived alongside you in my
husband's homeland in the highlands of
Sulawesi Island in eastern Indonesia
there is a community of people that
experience death not as a singular event
but as a gradual social process in Tana
Toraja the most important social moments
in people's lives the focal points of
social and cultural interaction are not
weddings or births or even family
dinners but funerals so these funerals
are characterized by elaborate rituals
that tie people in a system of
reciprocal debt based on the amount of
animals pigs chickens most importantly
water buffalo that are sacrificed and
distributed in the name of the deceased
so this cultural complex surrounding
death the ritual enactment of the end of
life has made death the most visible and
remarkable aspect of Rajas landscape
lasting anywhere from a few days to a
few weeks funeral ceremonies are a
raucous affair we're commemorating
someone who's died is not so much a
private sadness but more of a publicly
shared transition and it's a transition
that's just as much about the identity
of the living as it is about remembrance
of the dead so every year thousands of
visitors come to Tana Toraja to see as
it were this culture
death and for many people these
grandiose ceremonies and the length of
the ceremonies are somehow
incommensurable with the way that we
face our own mortality in the West so
even as we share death as a universal
experience it's not experienced the same
way the world over and as an
anthropologist I see these differences
in experience being rooted in the
cultural and social worlds through which
we define the phenomena around us so
where we see an unquestionable reality
death is an irrefutable biological
condition trajan see the expired
corporeal form as part of larger social
genesis so again the physical cessation
of life is not the same as death in fact
a member of society is only truly dead
when the extended family can agree upon
and marshal the resources necessary to
hold a funeral ceremony that is
considered appropriate in terms of
resources for the status of the deceased
and this ceremony has to take place in
front of the eyes of the whole community
with everyone's participation so after a
person is physical death their body is
placed in a special room in the
traditional residence which is called
the tongkonan and the tongkonan is
symbolic not only of the family's
identity but also of the human life
cycle from birth to death so essentially
the shape of the building that you're
born into is the shape of the structure
which carries you to your ancestral
resting place until the funeral ceremony
which can be held years after a person's
physical death the deceased is referred
to as Col McCullough a sick person or
toll mama
a person who is
sleeeeep and they continue to be a
member of the household they are
symbolically fed and cared for and the
family at this time will begin a number
of ritual injunctions which communicates
to the wider community around them that
one of their members is undergoing the
transition from this life into the
afterlife known as puia so I know what
some of you must be thinking right now
is she really saying that these people
live with the bodies of their dead
relatives and that's exactly what I'm
saying but instead of giving in to the
sort of visceral reaction we have to
this idea of proximity to bodies
proximity to death or how this notion
just does not fit into our very
biological or medical sort of definition
of death I like to think about what the
Trajan way of viewing death encompasses
of the human experience but the medical
definition leaves out I think that
Trojans socially recognized and
culturally Express what many of us feel
to be true despite the widespread
acceptance of the biomechanical
definition of death and that is that our
relationships with other humans their
impact on our social reality doesn't
cease with the termination of the
physical processes of the body that
there's a period of transition as the
relationship between the living and the
dead is transformed but not ended so to
Rajan's express this idea of this
enduring relationship by lavish love and
attention on the most visible symbol of
that relationship the human body so my
husband has fond memories of talking to
and playing with and generally being
around his deceased grandfather and for
him there is nothing unnatural about
this
this is a natural part of the process as
the family comes to terms with a
transition in their relationship to the
deceased and this is the transition from
relating to the deceased as a person
who's living to relating to the deceased
as a person who's an ancestor and here
you can see these wooden effigies of the
ancestors so these are people who have
already been buried I already had a
funeral ceremony these are called tau
tau so the funeral ceremony itself
embodies this relational perspective on
death it ritual eise's the impact of
death on families and communities and
it's also a moment of self-awareness
it's a moment when people think about
who they are their place in society and
their role in the life cycle in
accordance with Trojan cosmology there's
a saying in terrassa that all people
will become grandparents and what this
means is that after death we all become
part of the ancestral line that anchors
us between the past and the present and
will define who our loved ones are into
the future so essentially we all become
grandparents to the generations of human
children that come after us
and this metaphor of membership in the
greater human family is the way that
children also describe the money that
they invest in these sacrificial
buffaloes that are thought to carry
people soul from here to the afterlife
and children will explain that they will
invest the money in this because they
want to repay their parents the debt for
all of the years their parents spend
investing and caring for them but the
sacrifice of Buffalo and the ritual
display of wealth also exhibits the
status of the deceased and by extension
the deceased family so at funerals
relationships are reconfirmed but also
transformed in a ritual drama that
highlights the most salient feature
about death in the
place its impact on life and the
relationships of the living so all of
this focus on death doesn't mean that
Trojans don't aspire to the ideal of a
long life they engage in many practices
thought to confer good health and
survival to an advanced age but they
don't put much stock in efforts to
prolong life in the face of debilitating
illness or in old age it's said in
tragedy that everybody has sort of a
predetermined amount of life it's called
the Sunnah and like a thread it should
be allowed to 'unschool to its natural
end so by having death as a part of the
cultural and social fabric of life
people's everyday decisions about their
health and healthcare are affected the
patriarch of my husband's maternal clan
Nanette kaca
is now approaching the age of 100 as far
as we can tell and there are increasing
signs that he is about to depart on his
own journey for a puia and his death
will be greatly mourned but I know that
my husband's family looks forward to the
moment when they can ritually display
what his remarkable presence has meant
to their lives when they can ritually
recount his life's narrative weaving his
story into the history of their
community his story is their story
his funeral songs will sing them a song
about themselves and it's a story that
has no discernible beginning no
foreseeable end it's a story that goes
on long after his body no longer does
people ask me if I'm frightened or
repulsed by participating in a culture
where the physical manifestation
death greet us at every turn but I see
something profoundly transformative in
experiencing death as a social process
and not just a biological one in reality
the relationship between the living and
the dead has its own drama in the US
healthcare system where decisions about
how long to stretch the thread of life
are made based on our emotional and
social ties with the people around us
not just on medicines ability to prolong
life we like the Trojans base our
decisions about life on the meanings and
the definitions that we ascribe to death
so I'm not suggesting that anyone in
this audience should run out and adopt
the traditions of the Trojans might be a
little bit difficult to put into play in
the United States but I want to ask what
we can gain from seeing a physical death
not only as a biological process but as
part of the greater human story what
would it be like to look on the expired
human form with love because it's so
intimately a part of who we all are if
we could expand our definition of death
to encompass life we could experience
death as a part of life and perhaps face
death with something other than fear
perhaps one of the answers to the
challenges that was facing the US
healthcare system and particularly in
the end-of-life care is as simple as a
shift in perspective and the shipment
perspective in this case would be to
look at the social life of every death
it might help us recognize that the way
we limit our conversation about death to
something that's medical or biological
is reflective of a larger culture that
we all share of avoiding death being
afraid of talking about it if we could
entertain and value
other kinds of knowledge about life
including other definitions of death it
has the potential to change the
discussions that we have about the end
of life it can change the way that we
die but more importantly it could
transform the way that we live
karissa Bunga
[Applause]
[Music]